shut the drunk called in and he started
whining again that
you know i don't pick up the phone on
him enough it's the same thing over and
over you don't spend enough time with
him you spend more time with
everyone else why can't you
speak to me like you do the other wack
patches
like bobo high pitch
king of all blacks you talk to them
for a good half hour every other [ __ ]
week
and you talk to me for one minute and
you watch me
what the [ __ ] is up with that shulie
wants to debut his new jeff the drama
julie where did you find this puppet how
did you make it to give us the
background
so uh i found it actually my neighbor
across the street bought this puppet for
his kids
and the kids totally got freaked out by
it and hated it
so i saw it in his trash can a couple
weeks ago
outside getting ready to be thrown out i
looked at it and i was like
maybe i can make a jeff puppet out of
this it's it's nice and garbage
i said it's very funny it was born i was
gonna say how appropriate
i found so this is like a pet hat
[Laughter]
and then i bought these glasses on
amazon for like
two bucks and then i got his googly eyes
hey hey jeff how are you
do you guys even like me
well you know you even care about me
i do like you but i can't pick up the
phone on you all the time i can't what
the [ __ ]
you pick up on the hype is eric and
[ __ ] bobo
[ __ ] that you know julie you're so good
at this and the puppet's so funny i
don't think i ever have to pick up on
jeff again
[Laughter]
okay
whoa that was awesome listen to how you
cough when you take a hit
you gotta coughs to get off [ __ ]
you